New York State is taking dramatic action
to contain one of the country's largest
known coronavirus clusters a containment
area with a one-mile radius about three
square miles in all is being imposed on
New Rochelle just miles north of New
York City it's in one of the nation's
most affected counties with at least a
hundred and eight confirmed cases meg
Oliver is just outside the zone in New
Rochelle Meg how does this work
Michelle good morning the plan is
believed to be the first of its kind in
the country you're still free to come
and go but a ban on large gatherings
here is what the state hopes will help
lower the infection rate now one of the
highest in the nation this is literally
a matter of life and death New York
Governor Andrew Cuomo is calling the
corroded virus outbreak here in
Westchester County breathtaking and he
isn't taking any chances this will be a
period of disruption for the local
community I understand that local shop
owners don't like disruption nobody does
beginning on Thursday this one mile
radius of New Rochelle will be under a
newly enforced ban no large public
gatherings for two weeks that will shut
down a number of schools houses of
worship and community centers local
businesses like grocery stores can
remain open because of childcare issues
I don't know what I'm gonna do with my
kids for two weeks just having to
re-evaluate everything figuring out how
you're gonna get to work and deal with
the kids and stuff like that
we're also going to use the National
Guard the state has deployed the
National Guard to the New York City
suburb to help with sanitizing public
spaces and distributing meals to
students of shuttered schools who
usually rely on their breakfast and
lunch programs the National Guard will
be here in a very helpful logistical and
organizational support capacity it's not
as though nourish shell is going to
become a militarized community we're not
going to have checkpoints at the border
of the containment zone and so forth the
state is also bringing in a testing
facility here to New Rochelle inside the
containment area and an attempt to help
those people who believe they have the
virus from spreading it Anthony
Meg Oliver thanks Meg